la thématique est à l'honneur
aujourd'hui à thématique qui est
développée aujourd'hui c'est pour une
agriculture propre l'agriculture celle
l'agriculture sans bärtschi et ça c'est
quelque chose de remarquable à obtenir
parce que nos terres aujourd'hui en
martinique ne sont pas extensibles et
nous savons que il ya certaines parties
de nos exploitations qui sont connues et
parle d un certain nombre de pesticides
aujourd'hui il faut changer de modèle de
développement agricole il faut aller
vers une agriculture durable
l'agriculture à bout écologique une
agriculture sans pesticides sans
produits phyto sanitaires et
l'agriculture qui utilisent des
amendements naturel une agriculture qui
répondent aux aux attentes aux besoins
des consommateurs
mais une agriculture qui va permettre
aussi à l'agriculteur de vivre plus
décemment de son travail
quoique malgré la sécheresse malgré le
carême et qui bat son plein nous
agriculteurs savent où se préparer aussi
pour cette manifestation
parce que là mais la foire agricole et
artisanale qui a lu à lydia pilote
depuis 25 ans s'est inscrit dans les
annales de l'histoire de la vie à victor
martinez c'est une manifestation
continent donc on se prépare cette
manifestation bien d'autres avancent
donc je crois que ça aussi nos exposants
mais vite peut-être d'être applaudi
parce que il soulage eux et le public
pourra trouver un peu de tout
aujourd'hui à lille